welcome to the log vlog where we put the
log and vlog check out my blog where i
keep a log of all the logs
[Music]
good afternoon everybody we are in
idlewild california and we are about to
show you
a cool cabin and we're about to spend
the next couple of days relaxing and do
nothing we are
responsibility free yay no kid we are
going to try to work as little as
possible
puppy puppy just drove by driving the
car
so we are taking a vacation one final
vacation i guess before
summer ends officially ends yeah we
drove out to this cabin with some
friends so it's just the five of us
and no kids and we get to just chill
relax for the next
few days and just enjoy nature but we
got this really cool cabin
it's actually built with a boulder yeah
like for example
like if you could just look down and it
went right in my mouth there's another
cabin and look at the boulder that's
like built
like right beside or like i guess you
don't build a boulder next to you build
the cavern next to the
makes the boulder yeah we came with
deanna and andrew
oh you know what's crazy is on the way
up here so i recently found some footage
that we recorded on a gopro like eight
years ago
like 2012-ish right when we first
started dating yeah and we're all shy
and stuff with each other still trying
to learn each other and we have footage
of that
going on a road trip to norcal for a
camping trip sure we went up to big sur
yeah and yeah that was camping actually
it was in heaven it was with the same
people well same glass wasn't there but
yeah like close enough super fun that
was the very first time that we actually
ended up doing
something away from home and with
friends and we're spending the night
together so like for a new relationship
it's like oh my gosh
he's gonna like see me get ready in the
morning i don't know because like
we were just still like really really
new so i remember being really nervous
yeah the same same i was trying to poke
her face i was like i'm totally relaxed
and i'm just like oh insecurities all
the way first date first road trip
together
yeah you know what was so cute about
that trip too is that a couple years
after that
you had told me that that's when you
realized that you felt like you had
fallen in love with me or whatever
when we were walking through hearst
castle yeah we stopped by hearst castle
on the way
back yeah that was super cute last time
we had the time
because we were also like really broke
back then yeah we didn't have we were
kids like really young yeah and and so
we had this
one-person tent that we squeezed the
both of us in
somehow we made that work but i remember
being so uncomfortable because we had to
like
literally be like a little cocoon like
inside of a little cocoon that's not
true
and i was just like well this is really
close quarters
was it too close for comfort no is it
ever too close for comfort now
can we stay like this for a long period
oh yeah that's
too close for comfort because i could
feel your sweaty armpit oh yeah it's
like suction cuffed into your shoulder
that's disgusting okay i want to show
them the cabbage okay show them the cab
oh look at this this is kind of cool
didn't notice this on the way in
separation cool
don't climb that great
welcome to the co uh what is it i don't
know
boulder cabin this is like mtv cabin
look at this
here's marty there's a aak over there
and
what's up and the new hairdo i like it
oh yeah he bleached his hair
i didn't recognize him in the in the
parking lot when we first started
meeting up
yeah what's up everybody
over there look at that that's sick
that's different
that's the highlight of the highlight of
this trip is the boulder inside the
cabin
so then there's like a little loft up
there with the piano and that's when
alexa's gonna sleep
yep and then here's like the living
space mm-hmm
and then there's a bathroom over there
and then down here
[Music]
we're like one with nature down here you
know what's really weird too about this
cabin so
this is it came diana's room and this is
our room
don't poop here okay don't poop here
look how strange there is
carpet in this bathroom but also a
boulder yeah i was like
look how strange the car did
this bathtub are we gonna use this
bathtub
i'm super down it just feels so old here
true i'm like a lot of people been in
here it just feels really dingy and then
it's really grossing me out how there's
carpet i think marty knows marty knows
there's stuff
on this carpet imagine like just carpet
in the bathroom because look look at
their bathroom too it's really weird oh
there's a bathroom in here too yeah
look at this it's like this is not
normal
yeah it's because for guys guys would
know like
maybe a female bathroom is gonna be a
lot cleaner but for guys
no matter how clean and how well you
point
your pee stream it's always gonna bounce
you will get pee around the toilet room
so the fact that there's carpet
everywhere
kind of just like how well can you clean
the carpet really
yeah so it's just i don't think i've
ever seen carpet in a bathroom before
true so just seeing this i'm like what
was weird
true but i mean so is a boulder inside
the house
so true look at her i mean him i said
her
look at him because marty could be a
girl's name too true martina
martin scorsese oh yeah he's named after
martin's crusade
we're gonna be using later tonight
oh it's my favorite color too
it's more grand up up there but check
out the view
we'll go we'll look at the view from up
there in a second but look at that
that's nice
one with nature
[Music]
wow wow look at that and look at the sun
just hitting the mountain
it's nice oh yeah looks like cg
it's like it's a green screen it's not
real sometimes it's just important to
just
change up the scenery a little bit
responsibly
social distance
out here it's like there's no one around
here yeah it feels good though
yeah feels it feels good to be in nature
too i think when you're stuck at home
and you're just in behind four walls
it's it's just nice to
you know change it up and be like no
walls anyways i'm hungry let's go inside
and make some food yeah
i think this is all you're gonna see
this weekend because now we're gonna
just
relax yeah
[Music]
just uh you know last day cooking
everything we have left over and uh
right now these are just some breakfast
potatoes nice
kimchi fried rice
we're gonna go on an adventure marty
all right last day of cabin trip
in ottawa california and
we're hiking and these trees out here
are gigantic makes you feel very
small in the universe which is kind of
nice it's a nice little reminder how
small we are it makes you feel like you
haven't you're having an existential
crisis
[Laughter]
[Music]
dang it these flies are so invasive
they get like right by my ear and then
if i whack them like they still
like hover around yeah they're resilient
they're resilient set of flies
found a resting area tiff yeah yes
it's a throne for a queen protection
baby
i dare you to climb all the way in there
no that looks scary but if we were
trying to survive
perfect shelter there would you do you
think it's more dangerous sleeping in
there
than out here like like on the side of
the road if you were like to pass the
night
no way it's way safer in there yeah
protects you from animals
what if it's a home to another animal oh
good point you can literally lay in
there yeah
it's like it's like it's nature's
sleeping bag in there
yep it's crazy for
welcome to the log vlog where we put the
log and vlog check out my blog where i
keep a log of all the logs all right
we're finishing up the hike we decided
to go off road
so close baby
[Applause]
some fresh california here
[Music]
me